AND IT'S HANDS FULL WITH
THE REILLY KIND OF GROWLING STA
JOSE, BACK-TO-BACK, TORONTO  CA
NOTHING WRONG WITH THAT ONE.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU GO
TO THE FRONT
JARRY MAKES A SAVE AND A SECOND
ONE, CAN'T ON THE REBOUND.   CH
A SOFT-HANDED SHOT BY THE
VETERAN DID NOT  AND THE REBOUNE
BAR FOR
PIERRE ENGVALL, NEAR BOARDS THO
AND CHANGED THE MOMENTUM, THE
MATHESON IN THE ZONE, WRAP
AROUND AND H THAT PAD AND UNDER
GLOVE OF THE NET MINDER
SCORES!
ANOTHER ONE ANDFF THE LEAD
DEFENDER.
PERIOD.
KEEP THE PRESS
GOING TO FIND MUZZIN HERE, AND
MUZZIN GOES HIGH OFF THAT
THEN OF COURSE, YOU GET LUCKY
OFF THE SKATE OF
5-1 FOR THE IT,
BACK-TO-BACK AND THEN SAVED  PE
NOONE, HE WAITED GOALIE INTERFE
BUNTING FOR GREAT SCREEN BY GUE
RESULTS FROM YOUR HARDE SOME OF
THERE, THEY'LL TAKE YOUR HEAD
OFF.
>> YEAH, THEY'VE GOT SOME BIG
THE ICE.
THERE'S O'CONNOR AND STOPPED BY
HUTCHINSON.
>> TRYING TO GET 2020.
NEXT UP OVER TO CAROLINA.
YOU KNOW THAT WON'T